definitivamente es
realmente está haciendo un peligro para
las personas para desarrollar su
identidad al desarrollar también su
personalidad ya que está expresa mundo
también prohibido dentro de la educación
tanto pública como privada es decir que
esto viene desde una concepción no solo
desde la familia sino también como el
estado a abordar el tema e incluso hay
una prohibición expresa hacia los
funcionarios y los empleados y las
empleadas públicas y que incluso pueden
ser sancionados administrativamente y
posiblemente también penalmente en algún
momento con algunos de los delitos
administrativos incluidos en el código
penal entonces
definitivamente es un peligro para que
las personas puedan expresar su
orientación su identidad de género
también ya que expresa definitivamente
valores
que el estado considera respecto a la
heterosexualidad y solamente con la
concepción pues que ellos dicen natural
de la familia que es prácticamente como
ellos lo despiden en la ley la unión
entre hombre y mujer veíamos también una
marea verde en el continente con
distintos países dando vía libre al
aborto qué significa esto para guatemala
para guatemala significa un retroceso
prácticamente doblaron las penas habían
penas de 3 a 5 años en el aborto en
guatemala de hecho la tentativa de
aborto o el aborto culposo no estaba
penado en guatemala y ahora se pena con
una pena de alrededor de 12 años de
cárcel ninguno de los delitos
tipificados por aborto en guatemala
ahora pueden ser contables es decir que
se pueden pagar ahora todo se tiene que
la sanción va a ser únicamente prisión y
también sin que se introdujo un nuevo
delito que era la promoción del aborto
por parte de cualquier persona con fines
de lucro o sin fines de lucro y
definitivamente también implica un
cierre hacia el personal médico
inclusive ya que las penas van desde 12
a 50 años
señora guerrero otro tema es que ahora
la educación sexual debe estar a cargo
de los padres lo que implica que no será
impartida en los colegios qué
consecuencias podría tener esto para la
sociedad muy brevemente por favor muy
bien pues la educación siempre estuvo a
cargo de los padres pero lo que implica
ahora es que la educación pública o
privada tiene que regirse bajo criterios
de promoción de
valores heterosexuales y no
correspondientes a lo que le llaman la
identidad de género entonces
definitivamente esto va en contra
incluso de la constitución guatemalteca
que promueve los derechos humanos y la
tecnología como parte de los fines de la
educación